some have pointed with justifiable pride
and called him the new breed of fighting
man but if breeding is to be consistent
if it's to me in anything then this is
the same man that what ashore at Iwo
Jima Guadalcanal in child and only
yesterday at the Bataan Peninsula in
South Vietnam history has dictated few
changes in the life of the United States
Marine his primary mission is still the
winning of the battle
the battle is the culmination of months
and years of preparation suddenly all of
those seemingly small isolated moments
of rigorous training are funneled into a
few days a few hours when mobility
firepower and leadership must take on a
definitive pattern within the framework
of a calculated risk a pattern that not
only acknowledges the strengths and
weaknesses of the enemy but also the
time and a place where he can be
defeated the time 0 6 30 sep tember the
seventh nineteen sixty-five mission
operation piranhas afford a Search and
Destroy action by combined United States
and Vietnamese military forces against a
suspected stronghold of 2,000 Viet Cong
guerrillas on the twin peninsula's of
vertonghen and hongki 20 miles south of
Chula
for the men of the 1st battalion 7th
regiment this was the sort of operation
for which all Marines are qualified born
of time necessity and circumstance and
nurtured to near perfection under fire
during the Pacific campaign of World War
2 the amphibious assault has become the
trademark of the Navy Marine Corps team
a symbol of their role in America's
combat readiness
but even before the 1st battalion had
begun to assemble at its do barking
stations at sea the men of the 3rd
battalion 7th reforming up into copter
abortion sticks for loading at a hastily
constructed helipad near the outskirts
of to live
this was the vertical envelopment
doctrine in operation utilizing three
centrally controlled helicopter
squadrons the men of the 3rd battalion
were airlifted to landing zone Oak strip
of elevated ground running across the
Twin throats of batangas and on key from
here they would act as a blocking force
to the repeating Vietcong as the 1st
battalion began its push from the beach
with the completed landing the first
wave of Marines 16 of the choppers broke
away from landing zone oak and spent ten
miles south to the Republic of Vietnam
stronghold at Quang guy there they began
the hella lift of two Vietnamese
battalions to landing zones pine and
birch located on the far side of the
song chow mei dong River bio 945 the
vertical envelopment was completed and
the stranglehold across the windpipes of
batanga nan danke stretched for a full
eight miles
by late morning advanced marine patrols
had already moved in from the beach to
their first objectives and others formed
up ready to follow
on the outskirts of villages like chow
mei wan civilians were quickly gathered
together for safe transportation behind
the marine lions and as they moved off
the marine stopped small groups had
asked the same question over and over
again where are the Viet Cong the answer
that came back was always the same
they're gone they left before you came
the expected vehicon resistance at the
beaches had never materialized
and now even further inland only
scattered sniper fire broke this was the
penalty that the Marines had to pay for
their own efficiency the very strength
of United States firepower that had won
so many victories in the past had driven
the Viet Cong to cover or full retreat
the possibility of any single big
contact was going to be harder and
harder to come by
as night fell on their first day ashore
the Marines dug in and waited finally
the word came back only for Viet Cong
killed six captured 48 suspects being
held it was evident that an old familiar
pattern of battle was taking shape the
Marines had seen it before at places
like Iwo Jima Saipan and Guadalcanal
three of the four Viet Cong killed and
the previous day has been flushed from a
cave this could mean only one thing the
Viet Cong were there all right but
they'd have to be dug and blasted out
one key to the Search and Destroy
operation was the jet hot pad at you
live standing on strip alert marine
attacked Jets were only minutes away
from a platoon leaders radioed call for
an airstrike with almost any lethal
combination of weapons he might want or
need from 20 millimeter aircraft cannon
and high velocity rockets or bombs to
bullpup missiles
for the first time in Marine Corps
history control of the air support
elements was handled by Marines circling
above the battlefield at 18,000 feet in
the past the DA SC or director Support
Center during such operations has been
located on a communications ship lying
offshore this time a que si Hercules was
outfitted to do the job it screws
monitored requests from ground forces
and assigned aircraft to requested
strike areas
but if the innovations of the jet air
strike and das see fortunately
successfully piranha campaign the
backbone of the attack was still a man
on the ground the man with the singular
philosophy embodied in the words
leadership and discipline combat is a
test of courage and endurance a forced
inbreeding that teaches the individual
to respond to a command under any
conditioners it's a discipline struggle
for life hinging upon the absolute
control of those who command and the
unswerving loyalty of those who follow
by the end of the second day the Marines
had confirmed 70 Viet Cong killed four
captured
by the end of the third day the Viet
Cong resistance was broken one by one
the caves were opened up and the enemy
rotted out
when the smoke had cleared over one hole
the Marines discovered to their
amazement a limestone cavern over 6 feet
high and 250 feet long yielded up the
bodies of 66 dead Viet Cong after that
time it was the largest single kill made
by the Marines since their arrival in
vietnam by sep tember the 10th it was
all over batanga nan danke were secure
bored a total 198 Vietcong killed 38
enemy captured 265 bc suspects detained
the cost one marine dead eight would
while several elements of the marine
assault team were being withdrawn to
another battle area west of the Lang
others remained behind for while the
Marines had completed their primary
mission had won the battle there was
still a further American responsibility
the villagers needed food medical
supplies and continuing protection they
needed assurance that they were
realizing the beginnings of justice or
without justice security and self
dependency would never arrive all
Americans in Vietnam both military and
civilian know there's more than a
fighting machine for them in their
support of the embattled Republic of
Vietnam they have heard and understand
the words of President Johnson who said
a nation cannot be built by armed power
or by political agreement it will rest
on the expectation by individual men and
women that their future will be better
than their past when the final battle is
won in Vietnam
you